you're welcome to Hannity busy news
tonight tonight we are witnessing what
is a radical major shift in American
politics like you've never seen the new
far left extreme socialist Democratic
Party they are hitting new levels of
radicalism Muller didn't deliver on
their collusion fantasies by the way
rush was great earlier tonight wasn't he
when he said Oh Hillary needs to be in
jail and indicted if you did what she
did you would be in jail now the Trump
agenda succeeding that is driving them
off the rails it was on full display
last night fake News CNN put the 2020
Democrats on stage one after another
hour after hour of hardcore socialism
where they completely tried to out
socialists the other socialists on stage
from Pietschmann to trump open borders
guns oppressive taxes and of course yes
redistribution and the Green Deal we're
crazy Bernie Sanders was confronted
about the real failures of socialism
throughout history why would we not
learn from history and again from a
woman whose family actually fled the
former Soviet Union in 1979 take a look
my father's family left Soviet Russia in
1979 fleeing from some of the very same
socialist policies that you seemed eager
to implement in this country so my
question is how do you rectify your
notion of democratic socialism with the
failures of socialism in nearly every
country that has tried it is it your
assumption that I supported or believed
in authoritarian communism that existed
in the Soviet Union I don't I never have
and I opposed it and what democratic
socialism means to me is we expand
medicare we provide educational
opportunity to all Americans we rebuild
our crumbling infrastructure in other
words government serves the needs of all
people rather than just wealthy campaign
contributors all right of course Bernie
the socialist didn't have an answer
because everywhere his ideas his utopia
is put in place they always fail
remember keep your doctor keep your plan
save money
everyone millions lost doctors plans
have only one choice and everyone paid
more and it got worse because Sanders is
backing the right for all felons to vote
prisoners murderers yep even terrorists
like the Boston bombers can't make this
up take a look you have said that you
believe that people with felony records
should be allowed to vote while in
prison does this mean that you would
support enfranchising people like the
Boston Marathon bomber a convicted
terrorist and murderer but I think the
right to vote is inherent to our
democracy yes even for terrible people
so I believe that people commit crimes
they pay the price when they got out of
jail I believe they certainly should
have the right to vote but I do believe
that even if they are in jail they're
paying their price to society but that
should not take away their inherent
American right to participate in our
democracy shocking Bernie wants to take
more of your hard-earned money raise
your taxes eliminate all private health
insurance you only get the government
version good luck with that you get rid
of all fossil fuels you get rid of the
combustion engine we're gonna let sex
offenders murderers terrorists vote from
prison what a plan for America's future
and that is only one candidate look at
Kamala Harris took even her big
government agenda even further
California senator ramping up her
attacks yep on the second amendment
thinking we don't have a constitution
and we don't have co-equal branches of
government amazing moment take a look
there are people in Washington DC
supposedly ders who have failed to have
the courage to reject a false choice
which suggests you're either in favor of
the second amendment or you want to take
everyone's guns away
supposedly ders in Washington DC who
have failed to have the courage to
recognize you know what you want to go
hunting that's fine but we need
reasonable gun safety laws in this
country starting with universal
background checks and a renewal of the
assault weapon ban upon being elected I
will give the United States Congress 100
days to get their act together and have
the courage to pass reasonable gun
safety laws and if they fail to do it
then I will take executive action okay
quick Kennedy civics lesson for the
California senator
that's not how our constitutional
republic works our government works no
magical countdown clock that gives a
president sole authority to attack
constitutional rights because Congress
won't do what you want
remember with president Trump's
emergency declaration well within his
authority legislatively constitutionally
acting pursuant to a real law put out by
Congress passed by Congress to secure
the southern border granting him the
power to do so and something like the
Constitution commander in chief
Democrats they don't care about it last
night did you hear anything about
serious efforts to keep our nation safe
and secure remember two years four
thousand plus homicides thirty thousand
sexual assaults a hundred thousand oh
yeah file an assault by illegal
immigrant criminals two years now it was
just the opposite last night was it him
little good old mayor Pete genius that
he is talking about mass amnesty for
millions that didn't respect our laws
our Constitution our sovereignty and our
borders take a look there's a broad US
consensus that we need to find a way to
protect dreamers but as your question
brings out there are over 10 million
people who are undocumented immigrants
in this country who don't fall into that
category and the reality is we can't
have comprehensive immigration reform
that works unless it addresses the
status for those 11 some million
undocumented immigrants so what we need
to do is make sure there's a pathway to
citizenship for them too and of course
no democratic event would be complete
without yes even more lies and
conspiracy theories about Trump and
Russia even though we have four separate
investigations the FBI nine-month
investigation house Intel investigation
said it bipartisan investigation and
Robert Muller itself no collusion listen
to senator Warren calling for
impeachment with no basis she read the
Constitution take a look the tool that
we are given for that accountability is
the impeachment process this is not
about politics
this is about principle this is about
what kind of a democracy we have in a
dictatorship everything in government
revolves around protecting the one
person at the center but not in our
democracy and not under our Constitution
we have checks and balances and we have
to proceed here in a way understanding
our place in history
senator what part of collusion don't you
understand
and by the way senator I have another
question did Hillary Clinton break the
law the Espionage Act top-secret
classified information on that secret
server and was her intent to obstruct
justice when she deleted
bleech bit busted up devices with
hammers pulled out SIM cards now Warren
followed up that remark with more talk
about yeah higher and higher taxes
member she wants to legislate stealing
where after you pay all your taxes if
you happen to have any left she wants
the government to be able to say wait a
minute you saved too much we're gonna
now go back and take another bite at the
Apple and don't forget when you die even
pay a bigger bite of the Apple Wow they
always get there the golden your teeth
if they could and mass government debt
and forgiveness free college who's gonna
pay for all this take a look we are
going to roll back student loan debt for
about 95 percent of students who have
debt that's Part one and Part two is to
make sure that we never get in this mess
again on student loan debt and that is
to make college universally available
with free tuition and fees now when do
the rest of us get our refund I wrote
for 10 years to check the Jamaica
Savings Bank I only took out one student
loan and guess what 58 all five when I
didn't have any money by the way now
what we're seeing is a party that has
gone so far left that it even looks like
crazy creepy Uncle Joe Biden is having
some cold feet according to a new report
tonight he again pushed back his launch
which was now set for Thursday won't do
an official campaign kickoff until
Monday
and a new piece out in the Daily Mail
lays out the chaos surrounding Biden's
2020 quote rollout raising even more
questions about whether creepy crazy
uncle Joe even has a place in this new
radical Democratic Party we know they
hear some of the things we're about to
buys them up now that's pushing to get
rid of this is your new Democratic Party
remember Medicare for all would take up
most of the budget for ten straight
years that one the item gas and oil
remember we gonna get rid of the what is
the lifeblood of our economy the green
New Deal is 94 plus trillion dollars in
10 years letting felons vote open
borders and polishing ice Oh abolishing
the Electoral College of New York New
Jersey Illinois in California pick all
future presidents stacking the Supreme
Court with liberal activist judges
reparations crippling the Second
Amendment
they want a 70% top rate on individuals
marginal rate ninety percent on
corporations hmm well now many people
are going to invest in America and it
goes on now maybe you want to dismiss
all this maybe you want to laugh at all
this as just crazy unhinged madness but
these are really ideas within the new
radical socialist Democratic Party now
you have what over a hundred congressmen
and senators supporting Acacio Cortez's
new green deal all these presidential
candidates has supported these are ideas
that have been tried and have been a
massive failure everywhere they have
been tried you have any doubts look at
the promises of Obamacare keep your
doctor paying pay less how did that work
out for you causing tremendous human
suffering let's go to San Francisco
oh we sent our own Lawrence Jones back
yesterday we have exclusive footage just
ahead but I got to give a viewer warning
it's pretty disturbing what's going on
in Nancy Pelosi's backyard by the way
within walking distance to both her home
and office homelessness needles massive
wealth inequality sanctuary cities day
in and day out and yes feces and we've
got the video all over the place and
it's why so many people are fleeing
places like California New York New
Jersey Illinois where
all these progressive fairytales turn
out to be nightmares come to life and
why did Democrats why did it make such a
far left left turn why are they so out
of touch with hard-working law-abiding
common-sense Americans the people that
make this country great
why exploit people's innate natural fear
that they're going to take away every
fear that they have and take care of
everything of promises of everything for
free it is impossible they will never be
able to deliver it it's because the
Democrats well they're being led by a
new crop of radical leftist this is
their power base they make you dependent
you reelect them because then you're
voting back in the very benefits they're
promising to give you establishment
Democrats even as bad as they are
they're even terrified now of losing to
the far left base that if they want to
win re-election they're going to be
literally running on those programs
that's why extremists like Speaker of
the House Alexandria Acacio Cortes I
didn't misspeak are leading the party
Pelosi is really just speaker a name
only it's why every day she somehow
finds a way to top her previous bad idea
with one that's even worse the latest
you know she's dismissing efforts by the
President to reform the VA system to
help our vets say oh no everything's
fine well thankfully the president has
been fixing it take a look
[Music]
big bro
it's not just Speaker of Cascio portes
her radical cohort congresswoman Omar
who by the way is again embroiled in
scandals now remember first it was a
series of anti-semitic remarks by the
way what Bernie said last night about
Israel a downright disgrace for every
Democrat downplaying in this case
congresswoman Omar the 9/11 terror
attacks remember that now it's been
revealed that the Minnesota
congresswoman attacked the US soldiers
the ones that died fighting in the 1993
Black Hawk Down operation posting in a
Twitter thread Oh about nineteen US
soldiers dying in the battle of
mogadishu quote in his selective memory
forgets to also mention that thousands
of Somalis killed by American forces
that day hashtag not today Satan where's
that accountability where's the outrage
where are the Democratic leaders with
this is their party and where's the
media in this country you know if this
was a Republican they'd have gone insane
by now but we're here to do the work the
media doesn't do that is to expose how
radicals and how radical this party has
become and they don't even understand
simple basic fundamental things like the
law the Constitution separation of
powers co-equal branches of government
or any of the real consequences of their
actions like the green new deal which
comrade Bill DeBlasio he's now ramped it
up right here in New York City can't
wait for this to happen
wanting to take the city back to the
Stone Age that's Fred Flintstone for
those of you that are young at home you
know with Bill de Blasio's face on it
with the band quote inefficient ski
steel and glass skyscrapers because
they're bad for the environment so what
exactly does Bill de Blasio want to
build with I guess we can't use trees
because that would pillage the forest
the Democrats not understand these
materials they want a ban along with oil
and gas fossil fuels
it is the lifeblood of our economy in
every economy around the globe it drives
wages it drives opportunity for people
in this country it's why we are putting
this big new green deal disaster on
trial because Democrats want to rollback
all of the success of the Trump agenda
are you better off than you were two and
a half years ago I think the answer is
obviously yes like for example we're now
energy independent in America for the
first time in 75 years not relying on
countries that hate our guts for the
lifeblood of our economy and now we're a
net exporter of energy did you see this
forecasters now revisiting their first
quarter GDP estimates S&P 500 Nasdaq
closing again at record highs all while
Democrats want to recreate you know what
erode the entire middle class send us
back to Fred Flintstone's era Dino the
dinosaur they retreat to their rich
expensive enclaves surrounded by walls
and gates the success of The Forgotten
men and women the men and women in this
country that go to work pay their taxes
obey the laws raise their kids really
they're gonna get guaranteed from them I
don't think so it's going to be coming
from your able-bodied hardworking
Americans who they are chasing out of
big cities and if you leave New York New
Jersey California great don't bring
those stupid policies with you when you
go to Texas or the Carolinas or
Nashville in Tennessee or Florida they
want to build a better future for your
kids and grandkids
it's that entrepreneurial spirit the
freedom to find what you were made to do
your purpose in life your god-given
talents that is what drib has driven
success in this country it is what has
led this nation to becoming the greatest
civilization God has ever given man